we had Joe Thomas on the show Tyrell
Davis is gonna join us and we will have
a serious real-deal adult conversation
about NFL ownership and what's going on
with Jerry Jones and the rest of his
compadres and what's going on with the
NFL and general ratings wise when Don
Van Natta joins us in our number three
he is the one of the ESPN senior
investigative colonists and writers who
has written quite a bit on this subject
he's gonna stop by in studio and our
number three but we had Joe Thomas on
talking about what he tweeted about
earlier this week how he wants to be the
owner of next owner the Carolina
Panthers and he wants to rename them
account what the Carolina mission
barbecue and barbecue and how they're
gonna go for it on fourth down every
single time thus no need for punters and
kickers and when Joe called in last hour
of course I was going to ask him
specifically about that and here was the
the answer I think when you waste roster
spots on kickers and punters those are
roster spots that could be taken by more
left tackle so I don't see wasted on
kickers and punters but I got to tell
you Joe I mean certainly in these parts
as you know I'm a punters are people to
movement guy I'm I have an issue here
I mean punters of weapons Joe I'm not
sure I totally agree with you but there
are certainly people but I'm not sure
their football players oh wow fight
words people started tweeting about it
and tweeted at Pat McAfee bat mat Pat
McAfee show and the man who's in that
foxhole with me for the brand Pat McAfee
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
do you hear that Pat rich how's it going
well I gotta tell you I'm I'm a little
perturbed by what Joe Thomas had to say
I'm wondering what you think well just
like you were talking about Christmas
movies anytime somebody slanders the
brand it's much like when little Charlie
and the Santa Claus shakes the snow
globe in santa comes running that's kind
of what I feel like guys like you and me
do whenever punters or kickers are
bashed and I thank you for that from the
brand and from the bottom of my heart
well I appreciate that Pat you know you
know what I feel about this and and how
punters are weapons they they are they
are crucial members of a football team
and to hear them maligned in in a bid
for ownership in the National Football
I just won't stand for it Pat I won't
stand for and I there's there needs to
be 50 million retired is out there
because just like in Dateline you got to
look for a motive right let's look for
this motive from Joe Thomas to do a
terroristic type thought in eliminating
good American man who punt and kick
balls for a living he's trying to
eliminate America so let's remember that
the motive here is that you're talking
about one of the greatest left tackles
in the history of the game true who has
been held hostage by one of the greatest
failures in football history which is
the Cleveland Brown
he is a jaded soul everything he says
has to be come with a grain of salt
knowing that his his feel right now on
the whole maybe world is a little bit
negative for the situation he's been in
so you can't hold it against them
you just gotta hope that guys like him
get out there maybe own a team and they
realize that whenever left tackles and
left guards and centers and quarter
backs and wide receivers and all these
very tough I'm being serious when I say
that very tough guys can't get the job
done they roll out a punter to be the
janitor to clean things up
and that's just the way that Joe Thomas
needs to look at it we're not as tough
as you Joe
we're not as athletic as you now granted
I've had a lot more success in like
celebrating wins in the NFL than you
have had but we are the guys who got
your back and we're going to go to war
for you and that's what the brand is all
about is just looking out for their
teammates when they can and being the
janitor of the whole operation real
blue-collar cleaning it all up rich he's
just lashing out Pat right he's just
lashing out yeah he doesn't know what
he's thinking no idea about that like
you know how Darren McFadden it was on
the internet supposedly invested three
million dollars in Bitcoin like five
years ago and his financial adviser told
him no you didn't you don't have two
hundred and thirty seven million dollars
right now like you're supposed to you
have zero Millions you don't even have
the original three mmm
he's jaded Joe Thomas he his career was
that whole situation right there wasted
in one of the greatest cities in Ohio
he's jaded he doesn't mean it he's just
lashing out looking for some form to
feel better it's just a negative
situation that's been surrounding Joe
Thomas no it goes yeah so I'm again just
Pat what it all comes down to it um what
why do you think people like carpet on
the punters as low-hanging fruit Pat I
mean I'd love to just get to the root
issue here well rich I have the answer
for you and you're not gonna like it
okay a lot of the people your friends
that cover football games have negative
intelligence when it comes to special
teams absolute zero knowledge about
anything that's going on and there that
you are the voice of the game rich you
Joe Buck I believe is the voice of the
game to Torito Collinsworth these guys
who I look up to and enjoy a lot as
humans know jack squat about special
teams so when they're covering fourth
downs they don't do it properly
fourth sounds are a party they're a good
time and there's a lot going on just
nobody has a clue about it rich and I
believe that's the real answer
so should I next to my punters or people
to t-shirts that I've been Hawking for
quite some time should I have a t-shirt
that says I know jack squat should I
have that well I see I think you know a
little bit more I wish there was 15 but
you don't call game switch you're just
you're the guy in there that leads the
most electric pregame show on earth but
the actual game itself whenever four
sounds happened yes it's almost like Joe
Buck and Troy Aikman just go to the
bathroom they don't even act like it
exists nothing's happening let's talk
about a storyline somewhere else
it's a nightmare situation for the brand
but we're gonna get a fixed recharge and
that's what the internet village so was
there was there but then let's hit this
before I let you go Pat to your latest
episode of the Pat McAfee show on
barstool sports did did the did the Pro
Bowlers get it right Bret Kern in the
AFC and
also Johnny hacker in the NSA did they
get it right so right now we're in a
golden era of punters a lot of people
don't know that Ray guy was a
trailblazer a game changer but right now
you have some pandas launching footballs
on Sundays I think Bret turns one of the
most underrated punters in the history
of the game but Sam Cooke had a year
that's wild
Johnny hacker is an absolute monster an
absolute monster but if you were a
quarterback they make they take like 16
quarterbacks to the Pro Bowl for now but
for punter there's only one and there's
a lot of great guys there's a lot of fan
bases that are upset Sam Cooke had an
incredible run this year Justin Tucker
was doing his thing
Adam Vinatieri had quite a year and he's
in diapers almost it's just it's one of
those things where there's only so many
[ __ ] and there's an abundance of
greatness it's pat the poll question
before we let him go here Pat who would
you want if you're still playing who
would you want is your owner
the team of Diddy and Steph Curry Joe
Thomas Bon Jovi or Oprah oh man oh yeah
everybody gets rich if they know Oprah
you see dr. Phil that dude's got more
money than anybody so if I just meet
Oprah I think I might make a billion
dollars real quick I think you want to
play for the Oh for sure
play one for the other I like plus you
never know you go to the locker room
under the seat you get a car you got one
you never know would be amazing with
Oprah to help you get a car you get a
Pro Bowl nod you get a bonus I like that
a lot
yeah let's get Oprah in there for sure
yeah you dealt well you definitely want
Joe Thomas he'd put you out of the job
man
he'd put you on the street that's just
not right it's just not right terrific
terroristic terrorist organization tied
to that type of thinking by mr. Joe
Thomas but I think after he and I have a
few beers together his he will come
around completely okay take care of
yourself Patrick always love hearing
from you
you take care hey I appreciate you guys
have a good one good show here too I
like the design of the deception
watching it on the television what are
you coming out here how many times do I
have to invite you onto this set Pat how
many times okay
January 22nd through the 26th SiriusXM
I'm a morning show in LA from 7:00 to
10:00 barstool sports with rock
now that 7:00 to 10:00 locally here in
Los Angeles area or is that easy I know
out there okay I can't wake up that
early there's no way no way I retired I
don't want to set that alarm but yeah
okay nothing it's been morning show West
us I'll be out there 22nd through the
26th okay one of those days when you're
done we'll just we'll put you in a car
and you'll hang out with us here okay I
just I just don't know if I'm a big time
enough to hang out with rich ideas I
mean I I just don't know if I am well I
mean you you you you called me a voice
of the game but then said that I don't
have that much of a voice to try and do
what we need to do which is get the
honors credit I mean I've got I've got
coasters I've got t-shirts I've got a
voice I've got a platform I just don't
know what else to say Pat maybe just you
and I together we'll just figure it out
we'll brainstorm it was kind of a
backhanded compliment out of me merry
Christmas to you and yours Pat McAfee
hey thanks wrap me on rich have a great
one you gotta that's Pat mcafee show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience